PRIYANKA VERGADIA: A typical
customer service experience
requires multiple
conversational twists
and turns to achieve
the required outcome.
Stick around to learn how
Dialogflow CX simplifies
a complex conversational
experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I am Priyanka Vergadia, and in
this episode of "Deconstructing
Chatbots," we will help
our friends at PUggs
understand exactly
how a Dialogflow CX
conversation is defined and
visualized as a state machine.
Like any e-commerce
company, PUggs
has customers that call in
for ordering cute dog shoes,
and for returning
or exchanging them.
As you can imagine,
each of these topics
require multiple conversational
turns for the virtual agent
to acquire necessary
information for that customer.
That's where flows come in.
Flows are used to
contain and control
the definition of these
topics and their associated
conversational paths.
Here's how this works.
Every agent is automatically
created with one flow,
called Default Start Flow.
Sometimes this single
flow may be all
you need for a simple agent.
Look at this example.
Default Start Flow here provides
store hours, store location,
and helps place new orders.
But PUggs' case is a
bit more complicated.
They have different development
teams handling orders, returns,
and exchanges.
For situations like this,
agents require additional flows.
In this case, the
Default Start Flow
which is automatically
created for the agent
leads to the three additional
flows for orders, returns,
and exchanges.
So the three teams can
manage them independently
and use the Default Start
Flow as a single entry point
into the conversation.
Now, if we double-click
on any flow,
we find that it's a collection
of pages which represent
the state of the CX session.
At any given moment, exactly
one page is the current page,
and the current page
is considered active.
And the flow associated
with that page
is considered active as well.
Every flow has a
special Start page.
When a flow initially
becomes active,
the Start page becomes
the current page.
And depending on where the
user is in the conversation,
the current page will either
stay the same or transition
to another page.
Now let's understand pages.
Think of pages in
CX as web pages.
When we fill the fields
in the form on a web page
and submit it, we receive
a corresponding response.
Similarly, a page
in CX has a form
that is configured to collect
information or parameters
from the end users.
This information is
relevant to the conversation
state on that page.
Transition routes
decide where we
want to route the user
from the current page.
Now, let's see this in our PUggs
use case in the CX console.
I've created an agent already
to explain these concepts.
But don't worry, we will
be creating this agent
from scratch in
the next episode.
For now, if we go
in the Order flow,
we see the Start page,
which will become active
when the Order flow
triggers and routes
to the Collect
Information page, which
collects the parameters
shoe size and the color,
and routes the customer
to the Confirmation page.
If the user confirms, we end
the flow with the End Flow page.
And if the user
does not confirm,
then the page routes them back
to the Collect Information page
to capture those parameters
of shoe sizes and the color.
For more details on the
lifecycle of a page,
I've added the links
in the description.
The transition
routes would depend
on intents, which
represents something
our users want to do during a
conversation with our agent.
For example, here in
PUggs' order flow,
the Start page has a transition
route to Order intent,
where we expect the
user to provide us
the size and the color of
the shoe they want to buy.
Here we also add the multiple
training example phrases
for what customers
might type or say.
Depending on what
they say, the intents
are matched appropriately
and the parameter values
are extracted, such as the
size and the color of the shoe.
Now, if you've used
Dialogflow Essentials,
then I want to point out
here that the intents in CX
have been simplified to make
them more reusable resource.
Going back to the
parameters, they
have a name and entity type.
Entities are used to control
how data from the end user input
is extracted.
So here, the @sys.color
is a system entity
that refers to color, and
@size is a custom entity
that refers to the shoe size.
Now, back to the
page for a second.
If the transition route from
the page leads to a form
where we collect some
parameters from the user,
we need to either do something
with these parameters
or provide the user
with a response.
In PUggs' case, we
call the Order intent
and have the user
provide us with the size
and color of the shoes.
Then in the Collect
Information page,
we check the condition, if both
of these pieces of information
are collected, and only then we
route to the Confirmation page.
Until then, we stay
on the page to get
those pieces of information.
On the Confirmation page,
we actually get back
to the user using
the fulfillment.
Here I've added the static
text, but this would ideally
be a dynamic text based on the
information coming from PUggs'
back end through a webhook.
All right.
So that was a quick summary of
how pages and transitions work
in Dialogflow CX, along
with a glimpse of the PUggs
virtual agent.
Now that all the foundational
information is out of the way,
I am excited for the
next episode, where
we will start building
the PUggs conversational
experience in Dialogflow CX.
Until then, comment
below to let me know
your thoughts on this episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]